welcome to Table Talk my name is Brett
pastor at the table in Sachse Texas and
here's my big idea for today so most of
us believe that the world needs to
change question is how will that change
come about in other words will it happen
by changing systems and structures or
will it happen by changing individual
hearts and minds so these velocities
have changed span many different
political and religious perspectives but
the ways that they differ is it's often
like more sensed than really clarified
and named so for example I grew up in a
religious tradition evangelical
Christianity that tended to focus more
on the changing of individual hearts and
minds really weren't that into political
organizing at least at the grassroots
level I mean we'd like go and vote in
things but we really focused on the one
to one change that happens as I interact
with a person in front of me now this
was particularly true when I was younger
over the years that started to shift
but like I'm thinking when I was you
know this is thirty years ago it was
more that so everything was very local
was very hands-on but it firmly believed
that this is how change happens right
one heart one mind at a time so for
example if you wanted to see the divorce
rates plummet or the percentage of
people in poverty cut drastically the
idea was you worked with them at the
one-to-one individual level for example
the influential Tibetan Buddhist leader
and teacher the Dalai Lama in 2017 he
said change in the world always begins
with an individual who shares what he or
she has learned and passes it on to
others you can kind of hear there a
certain emphasis on the individual
however as I grew up I learned that
there was another approach to change
this perspective believes that change
happens at the systemic and structural
level first and then through that
systemic change it impacts the
individual for example if you want to
eliminate poverty the idea is then you
look at the broader systems the
structure
that create the circumstances in which
poverty flourishes or if you want to
reduce the divorce rates then you
analyze again the systems that create
the circumstances in which divorce runs
rampant same for abortion same for
alcoholism or any other social ill so
why this like pendulum swing why this
either/or approach well both
perspectives have their own great
insight those emphasizing the
individualistic perspective want to make
sure that the idea of for example
personal responsibility is not simply
ignored and done away with and I think
there's truth and now they're right to
do that any psychologists can tell you
that learning to take responsibility for
your life this is a huge step towards
maturity
however those emphasizing the systemic
side of things want to make sure we
understand the context in which people
take responsibility is a very big deal
and cannot be ignored as Martin Luther
King jr. said it can be cruel to tell a
man without boots to pull himself up by
his bootstraps and so it's easy right to
look at for example the homeless and say
well they got to take personal
responsibility for their lives
yeah and there's truth in that and yet
on the other hand we also know that
anywhere from 25 around 25 percent of
the homeless struggle with mental
disorders right so you can see how
homelessness that crisis is also a
systemic mental health crisis it's not
as simple as saying get your act
together so okay so what's the punchline
what am i driving out here how does
change in our world have happen the
answer is of course that we don't have
to choose the individual or the systemic
we can work along both lines at once
this is true in our personal lives this
is true in our politics and our churches
and our communities and yet too often
we're so beholdin often to our political
parties way of seeing that we turn a
blind eye to the truth and the other so
left-leaning political folks emphasize
the systemic conservatives emphasize the
individual but this is one of those
areas where seeing the truth in both
will probably get us further
in the long run this is a quote from
theologian Jurgen Moltmann which is a
Christian theologian and he puts it this
way change yourself some say and then
your circumstances will also change the
kingdom of God is supposed to have to do
with like only with persons
unfortunately the circumstances will not
oblige capitalism racism in the inhuman
technocracy techno Achra see quietly
develop in their own way the causes of
misery are no longer to be found in the
inner attitudes of men but have long
been institutionalized change the
circumstances others say and men will
change with them the kingdom of God and
freedom is supposed to be a matter only
of circumstance and structure
unfortunately men will not obliged
breakdowns and marriage drug addictions
suicide alcoholism continue undisturbed
structures which make people unhappy can
be broken down but no guarantee is
attached that men will be happy thus
both must be done at the same time
that's all for today you like this video
please click the like button comment
share it subscribe to my youtube channel
or anywhere you can find podcasts by
searching Brett Tilford tabletalk grace
and peace